les Russes avaient laissé entendre hier
que d'autres épisodes allaient suivre
menaces mises exécution aujourd'hui
puisque de nouveaux bombardements nous
ont donc été signalés tout à l'heure
dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine trois
explosions ont été entendus dans la
ville de ville une infrastructure
critique nous dit-on a été visé sachez
que depuis hier de nombreuses localités
un son privé d'électricité et d'eau
chaude en raison des attaques contre les
sites stratégiques énergétiques des
dizaines de villes ont connu cette nuit
à blackout et de façon générale on est
aujourd'hui sur le qui-vive on va
retrouver tout de suite notre équipe
déployée à carquive Mélina Huet bonjour
vous êtes notre envoyé spécial car qui
vous les sirènes d'alerte là aussi on
retentit à plusieurs reprises depuis ce
matin on aperçoit des Ukrainiens
certains d'entre eux qui ont trouvé
refuge dans les stations de métro
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait Elisabeth ralphi la deuxième
plus grosse ville du pays qui n'a pas
été épargnée par les bombardements au
tout début de la guerre et qui à nouveau
connaît cette angoisse d'entendre les
sirènes retentir de façon régulière
toute la nuit également ce matin ça
s'est calmé depuis quelques heures
maintenant mais ce matin effectivement
nous avons rencontré des personnes qui
se sont réfugiés à nouveau dans le métro
alors même que les wagons continuent de
circuler il y a encore des tentes des
personnes qui sont restées là depuis
mars mais d'autres qui sont redescendus
des jeunes notamment qui sont
redescendus cette nuit car ils n'ont pas
d'ambris d'abris en anti-aériens chez
eux ce matin plusieurs dizaines de
missiles ont été envoyés depuis
notamment et bien la Russie notamment
des localités à côté du Kazakhstan
également depuis la mer et certaines
ont touché différents oblates notamment
zapolijah mais également ni pro faisant
plusieurs blessés quelques morts et puis
vous l'avez dit en introduction le
vivent a été touché essentiellement sur
ces infrastructures à la périphérie des
centrales électriques et du coup ça a
créé effectivement des coupures de
courant des blackout il y a encore 30%
de la ville de le vivre contrairement à
ralphiph qui a récupéré la lumière hier
soir et qui est privé de courant et le
maire de la villa en juin la population
à faire des stocks d'eau car il pourrait
y avoir des pénuries dans les prochaines
dans les prochains jours au moment où
nous nous parlons Mélina les pays
membres du G7 sont censés se réunir par
visioconférence autour de vous le dit
merci le président ukrainien quelles
sont les attentes des Ukrainiens que
vous avez rencontré vis-à-vis de cette
énième réunion
écoutez tout à l'heure je vous parlais
de Yulia qui est dans le métro de ralkif
qui vit quasiment exclusivement depuis
les débuts de la guerre en mars dernier
on lui a demandé pourquoi vous n'en
sortez pas c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
épisodes des hauts et des bas avec un
failli être prise par les Russes il y a
encore quelques semaines quasiment
encerclé et jamais occupé mais elle nous
disait ok peut-être que ça s'est un
petit peu calmé ces derniers temps mais
moi il est hors de question que je sorte
de là tant que notre ciel n'est pas
protégé et c'est essentiellement ce qui
revient quand on échange avec les
Ukrainiens ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois c'est il nous faut
absolument un système de défense entière
efficace ils veulent également qu'il y
ait plus d'armes et de matérielles
lourdes notamment on parlait à Yuri qui
est l'un de nos collègues ici
journalistes ukrainien qui disait nous
ce qu'on veut c'est des missiles des
missiles attaqués des chars on peut pas
seulement compter sur l'aide des
Américains il faut aussi que que
l'Europe mette la main à la poche et au
niveau politique ce qu'il demande mais
ils sont beaucoup à le demander c'est
que les États occidentaux connaissent la
Russie comme un état terroriste les
Mélina Huet en direct de kerkif pour
France 24 Merci à VOUS accompagné de
Castries nord-estrent